in this video i'm going to tell you a
story about how i solved to churn for
the entire gym industry and i think
there are a lot of things you can take
from this
both in the actual outcome itself but
also the process
that was used to achieve it
one of the things i'm going to i'm going
to rewind the time clock here so for
those who don't know me i had a chain of
gyms in california um
i was founded in 2013 i had six gyms by
by 2016 that i grew uh just using cash
flow from the the growth of the
facilities
and so i was very good at the marketing
and selling process of getting people in
the gyms and opening them at full
capacity which was kind of my claim to
fame over time i then uh pivoted to
licensing uh that acquisition system to
other gym owners across the u.s right so
that was kind of the the path and then
jim mulch kind of took off from there
there was a two-year stint in between
there where i did turnarounds and i'd
fill other people's gyms up uh for a
percentage of the revenue that i was
bringing in right so that was kind of
that's the the long story short now fast
forward and uh now we've got thousands
of gyms right uh this is still a few
years ago but fast forward in the story
it's got a few thousand gyms at this
time one of the issues is that all these
guys are bringing people in the door but
they can't retain them for a long time
so they can convert them into members
because we had a process around that
which again was sales but uh they
couldn't keep them for a long time right
and this was and this wasn't because of
the acquisition system they just
couldn't keep any of their customers for
a long time and so what's interesting
about this is that this is for any type
of service based business that has any
kind of recurring you know uh revenue
model whatsoever and so here's what i
did to solve a problem that i did not
know the answer to all right so this is
the this is the takeaway that you can
you can take from this
so what i did was i said hey guys has
anyone in this huge community uh
achieved three percent monthly churn or
less for six straight months all right
so three percent monthly turn if you do
the math on it
let's actually look together shall we so
if we want to see how much
what percentage of your customers are
staying and if you have let's say three
percent monthly churns that's
0.97 right
and let's say that this is for 12 months
all right so we're going to go x to the
y for 12 months
that means that i'm going to keep 69
of my customers i'm going to lose 31 of
my customers year over year if i have 3
monthly churn that's still a decent
amount of customers that we're losing
right just being real with you now 3 is
like the top 1 percent of gyms i'll be
real with you like most gyms do not do
that the industry average is about nine
percent now if you want us to have
something that freaks you out let's just
do this one together so nine percent
means we're retaining 91 per month now
we're going to do our little twisty
twistiness so that we can do our fancy
math we go x to the y and we'll do 12
months again right right
look at the difference there
32
of your clients are still there meaning
you lose 68 of your of your recurring
clients if your monthly churn is nine
percent
this is why people don't want to buy
these types of businesses this is what
makes your business unsellable and so i
had this problem right i was like all
these gyms are acquiring customers and
their industry average is that they're
going to lose uh three quarters you know
of their customers by the end of the
year right
right this is a problem because i'm
going to have to keep showing them all
these new tips and tricks to get new
people in because literally by the end
of the year they're going to have
already turned over three-quarters of
the customers right this is a problem so
this is what i did i put a poll in the
group and i said hey if you've had less
than three percent monthly churn for six
straight months i'd like to invite you
to a round table
so 20 people out of the you know
thousands or so they were in the
community at the time 20 all right it's
a very small percentage said hey i i
meet this qualification so i said okay
so if you think about this math wise
right i've already got the top one
percent
um i guess this is the top two percent
but top two percent of the entire entire
gym world and so i had them all together
on a call and i said i need you to tell
me every single thing that you do
to provide uh excellent value or a
customer surplus uh to your members
right and so i went person by person by
person and i would sit there and i was
like and then what do you do and then
how does that work and then why do you
do that and xyz right and i wrote down
every single thing that every one of
them had and so by the end of this i had
like four pages of notes right so this
is what i did next so that you know we
ended the call and so i looked through
all the notes and then i re-categorized
them because a lot of them were
repetitive some of them were you know
different you know one-off weird things
and so i said okay
it's clear that all of them do lots of
things and the first one being they
actually track it and focus on the
metric which 95 of people don't even do
which is why most people are poor
number one
second thing that all of them did is
that they had lots of different
strategies to to combat churn because
they know uh that and you guys want to
know something crazy of course you do
we're watching the the world's coolest
youtuber all right so uh
if you let's say let's say you have a
service that's 100 a month okay 100
bucks a month
and let's say that your churn is three
percent right because that was the that
was the goal of these people right so
three percent churn all right and so
what i did was i did a hundred divided
by three percent
that's thirty three hundred dollars of
ltv right
lifetime value right lifetime amount of
revenue they're gonna be able to collect
over this customer if they pay a hundred
dollars a month you're gonna get 33
months out of this person because it's
100 divided by 0.03
watch this
same 100 price point remember i said the
industry average was nine
divided by point zero nine
eleven eleven all right eleven hundred
bucks is what the ltv of those gyms are
so the people who had conquered their
churn made three times more revenue per
customer than everyone else
but here's what's even crazier about
that if you make three times more
revenue per customer think about how
much more profit you're making
a lot more all right and this is why
this is such an important thing so a lot
of them were doing lots of things i
consolidated all of the things into
buckets and then i said what are the
things that every single one of them is
doing and you can think about this like
a voting system if if
if all of them are doing one thing then
that's probably an important thing if
i've got 20 guys and there's something
that only one of them is doing it's
probably not important because the other
19 are accomplishing the objective
without doing it and so the goal is how
little how few of these things are the
things that are actually driving the
outcome okay
and so what i ended up figuring out uh
after doing this entire process is that
there were five things that they were
all doing
to maintaining their members now you can
either say oh okay alex well the next
five things that he's going to share are
probably only for gyms
yeah because humans are totally
different in your business but anyways
so let's rock and roll
first thing that they were all doing
all of them
is that if someone missed uh and uh
they're they're not showing up at the
gym by wednesday of that week so they
missed monday miss tuesday
they
escalated them and they had all of them
had different processes around this some
of them did it by friday some of them
did it by tuesday but the end point was
if someone was not consuming the service
they immediately escalated it and would
repeatedly try and contact them to get
them scheduled for time to come in which
means they had accountability around
consumption
number one number two
the vast majority of them had exit
interviews meaning if someone wanted to
leave they would have to come in and
talk to somebody and there's two
benefits to this one is you get to
identify the things that are wrong with
your business because these people will
tell you why they are leaving this gives
you the opportunity to fix things that
are not good which is great which is
incredibly valuable data right number
one number two is a lot of times people
just need to vent and the things that
they're venting about it sounds like
pain means it can be solved which means
a lot of times over half those people
get resold into a higher level package
it's like no one ever contact me is like
well you're not in the contact me plan
you're in the you know do-it-yourself
plan you should get into the into the
coaching level where we actually hold
you accountable oh i didn't know you
guys had that yeah we just didn't know
that you needed that ah that's our fault
we should have asked you better
questions on the front end right right
cool and then all of a sudden this
person goes from being a loss
and a cancel
to being an ascension
so number one they make sure people are
consuming
number two
they save exit interviews so they can
collect data and to send existing
customers
number three
they all
did member events all right so they had
some sort of community component that
happened on a regular basis the the
extent to which they had it uh was
different the cadence was different but
i'll tell you right now that if you do
it on a quarterly basis uh that usually
works you know for in terms of bringing
the community together you're usually in
good hands number four is that they had
handwritten cards that they would send
out
on a regular basis to
each of the people
in their community and some of them
would send it out with gift cards to
bring friends which is a great way to
generate referrals as well some of them
would just have it as appreciation
some of them would give them some sort
of kudos or or whatever and here's the
key point about how these cards had to
be written they had to be personalized
all right so it can't just be hey thanks
for being a member love you lots send
er doesn't work
it has to be hey charlotte
you've really been advancing on your
pull-ups and if you're like well this
only works for gyms i'm not even going
to
comment on that use your brain
can you personalize something to any
kind of improvement that someone has had
in your business
probably hopefully but it's like hey
charlotte you've made a lot of progress
in your pull-ups when you got here you
had to use the big thick black band and
now you're using the yellow band which
is you know twice is twice as uh
hard in terms of the resistance level
for you keep you know keep it up you're
doing a great job and you're already
down 10 pounds so they're also reminding
them of the victories that are happening
right on a recurring basis and the fifth
one i honestly cannot remember what the
fifth one was but the point of this
story is the process of solving the
problem right that was the point all
right the process of solving the problem
and that you can use this for any type
of complex problem that you have and so
the way that this is done this is called
a consultative method but you go and you
talk to experts in the space so if you
sit on top of a community
all of the solutions to all of the
problems that you have already exist in
that community someone has solved it and
so all you have to do is get all the
smartest people in one room and then
interview them
tabulate the answers use a weighing
system of which of these answers comes
up most frequently
and then consolidate to what are the
fewest number of these things that
everyone is doing to solve this complex
problem and a lot of times when you use
that type of process and that type of
thinking you will be able to solve
the more complicated issues that come up
in business and a lot of times the
payouts can be rich and very rewarding
all right oh remember the fifth thing
every two weeks they were able to
contact them on a personal basis
independent of uh the service based
stuff so it's just checking in on them
as humans every other week or so so it's
like hey
you know imagine your phone buzzes with
a text
every 14 days every 21 days or so
and it says hey uh just checking in
how's life how's you know how's things
how you doing um just just making sure
everything's great and uh you know just
want to help you you know accomplish
your goals whatever right and so uh you
get that text from your service provider
you're like wow it almost appears as
though
they care
isn't that wild of course it is and that
is why people pay you to pay attention
that is what they are literally paying
for all right people want your attention
and so do not automate what you should
systematize it's one of the things i
have when it comes to service as soon as
someone finds out that communications
are automated they stop paying attention
because you stop paying attention to the
communication that's a little a little
nugget little little tidbit for you as
well is that do not automate what you
should systematize
okay you can have a system around
something just do not automate it
because as soon as human touch is gone
people stop caring about it all together
and it actually withdraws goodwill from
the goodwill bank account of your
customers rather than depositing it's
better to say nothing at all than to
automate things for the most part many
times i have found when it comes to
customer success and getting people to
believe that you give a [ __ ] which is
kind of the point of most services okay
so um the best way as a total side note
of getting people to think you give a
is to actually give a [ __ ] so with that
i will leave you mosey nation keeping
awesome if you're new to mozy nation
welcome we love you we appreciate you
keep being uh awesome we make these
videos because there's a lot of broke
people and i don't should be one of them
um if i didn't say this at the beginning
because i always forget my name is alex
mosey i own acquisition.com and about 85
million a year and say with me i have
nothing to sell you keep being awesome
see you next video bye